[Music]
my mom wanted to give kindly and leah
this opportunity to have their singing
and shining moment however after
listening to them saying it's in the
group's best interest to let everybody
audition for these parts this week is
very important to especially me and my
mom because last week i didn't get to
sing i didn't get to be in the spotlight
and if i don't get my spot this week
then i could potentially go home
come on and let me see you shake your
tail feathers come on and let me see you
shake it down
[Applause]
[Music]
you've been dancing with all over the
neighborhood
so why don't you ask me baby
or didn't you think i could
that was a really good breakfast as much
as i wanted leah to hang on to her spot
she just didn't come through for me i
mean brooklyn came in and swept it
brooklyn wanted it
let's see it tatum
come on let me see you shake your cells
feathers do it right shake it shake it
baby
head over let me see you shake it tell
feathers shake it out baby
she forget the words yeah yeah okay you
can't forget the words
on stage
this would cause a domino effect who's
singing the next part and when do they
come in how are they gonna know their
cue there's gonna be silence are the
kids gonna be dancing to silence
there is
no room for air right now
tatum
i'm sorry today we're saying goodbye to
you
i just want to say thank you
[Music]
i can't either
leah i had a bad week with your mom
[Music]
i think your mom's actions are awful
i've gone round and round with my mom
about today's decision
i will always fight for my mom and fight
for her to be treated right
because that's what my people around me
deserve
i will not tolerate my mom being treated
bad
ever
especially by someone who i've only
known for five weeks
you're not gonna sit in the studio pout
in the corner be a [ __ ] to my mom and
then expect me to like you
forgive and forget is a thing
for me i don't forget
leah if i keep you i'm showing all the
moms that
you can treat me bad and it's okay
i've worked
my whole life you know struggling things
up to get here
i love everyone here
and i don't want this to be the end i
want to keep going
[Music]